this video is sponsored by ground news
hello and welcome to the world of office
work what if I told you this epic
inspiring environment of meaningful work
and colleagues you like is about to get
even awesomer office 2.0 the open plan
office where we get rid of all partition
walls where workers no longer have any
privacy and are forced to spend eight
hours a day shoulder to shoulder at
tables that look like Lan parties this
epic solution will promote cooperation
upgrade socializing processes decrease
downtime coefficients and improve
employee performance indices now some
unepic individuals might say things like
forcing people to socialize is a bad
thing or The Chronic lack of privacy
damages people's mental health or
according to studies employees and open
plan offices are less likely to
cooperate to lad's baseless concerns
corporate has purchased some additional
office equipment privacy couches if
self-respect just isn't your thing
privacy covers because to corporate you
are a worm I mean future butterfly
privacy phone boots with glass walls so
you never get too relaxed and complacent
and last but not least privacy loved
walls for those who want privacy without
privacy
um how about just normal offices with
walls instead of all this expensive
[__] to Compass it for a
fundamentally hostile design
get back to work one more word and we're
shipping off your jobs to [__]
Bangladesh if you couldn't tell I myself
used to work in open plan offices and
they all sucked imagine being stuck in
an 8 Hour silent land party with people
you don't like where the only game
available is Microsoft Excel none of us
could ever concentrate properly people
constantly moved around and made noises
had phone calls and I always felt like I
was being watched after a few months
each of my colleagues sitting around me
had some annoying habit that drove me
nuts chewing too loudly tapping their
foot slamming their keyboard it all sent
my blood pressure Sky High in an
instance a workplace induced Cabin Fever
none of us talked with each other
everyone constantly had headphones on
trying to ignore each other instead of
going to someone sitting a few meters
away to talk with them we just used our
chat programs of course management was
completely oblivious to this they all
had private offices by the way and when
they occasionally sent down some
two-nothing middle management idiot to
see if our office needed anything to the
Privacy issue the response was oh
distributed and Zone privacy methods to
enable people to be direct personal best
and create a tailored experience that
support Rejuvenation and focus and
playing with balance in mind yeah cool
how about some goddamn walls we never
got our walls or our privacy because
management sitting in their private
offices knew that the open plan office
was best for us the employees and it's
not like we could vote to have the walls
installed the boss would have left in
our faces what is this a democracy
people can't be trusted to have
Democratic control over their workplaces
next thing you know they will start
demanding Democratic control over their
countries as well and so 99 year old
billionaire Charlie Munger took his idea
and said yeah this sounds about right
time to torture some college students
thus Monger Hall was born AKA Thor
Mozilla a single enormous cubicle
student dorm housing 4500 students or 11
floors and 148 000 square meters in dorm
rooms without Windows Architects are
naturally Overjoyed about this whole
idea whose sole originator is Charlie
Munger who does not have any
architecture training and designed the
bill building himself without involving
any of the students in the process for
whom the building is actually meant
because of course the plebs need the
benevolent billionaire to decide for
them why did the University of Santa
Barbara let Monger do this because he's
the one financing the project the well
there's your problem podcast also
covered this by the way I recommend you
check them out after watching this video
so why is Monger holy terrible idea
aside from the whole entombing students
in a concrete sarcophagus let's find out
you might have read about this project
online and a great way to do so is on
ground news ground news lets you combine
stories and articles from thousands of
sources in one place to give you a full
well-rounded picture of what's being
reported globally it helps reveal media
bias and displays additional information
about the new source such as level of
actuality ownership country of reporting
and other useful bits they also provide
you with a useful summary at the top of
the page ground news also lets you
follow specific topics such as who Tesla
news my favorite there's also blind spot
a page showing you topics on the
reported either by left or right leading
news sources oh and there is also a
handy browser extension where when
reading an article you can quickly check
and compare other sources reporting on
the same issue there is also an app
which has a map feature showing you
what's being reported in specific
locations in the case of articles about
Monger Hall as you can see the bias
distribution is to the left and it is
reported on by news outlets mostly of
high factuality comparing the language
of headlines can also be very useful in
detecting bias with such practical
breakdowns and handy prompts ground news
incentivizes readers to think freely by
properly contextualizing stories in a
transparent informative list of sources
this is a way to uncover media bias and
hold media accountable in the world
increasingly filled with informational
White Noise stay fully informed on
breaking news compare coverage and avoid
media bias go to ground.new Adam and
sign up for free or subscribe for
unlimited access big thanks to ground
news for sponsoring today's video and
now back to the program so Monger Hall a
99 year old billionaires master plan to
torture students with the full support
of the University of Santa Barbara what
is wrong with this project what is wrong
with it decrepit billionaire designing a
Maximum Security Prison for students to
live in let's find out
Monger Hall is supposed to be built on
this side owned by the University of
Santa Barbara the site is pretty far
away from the rest of the campus though
if you have classes on the south side
you're looking at a good 25 minute walk
meanwhile the very center of Campus is
dotted with parking lots why not build
dorms there instead right next to Monger
Hall's side are stadiums Sports Fields a
fire and police department and also the
county of Santa Barbara Community
hazardous waste collection center
and the center one of our airport where
apparently small prop planes still use
leaded fuel UC Santa Barbara the
excitement of discovering exotic
elements from the periodic table in your
bloodstream I had no idea the windowless
rooms also double as chemical Hazard
safety pods speaking of
as I mentioned the dorm rooms will be
completely windowless this is the main
source of controversy for the project
for good reason instead of Windows
students will get a smart LED screen
imitating natural light and the cycles
of dead why because Charlie Munger
decided this is what's best for you the
university actually had a mock-up build
where everyone could see what the dorm
would look like in practice instead of
just shiny renders and it's not much
better I mean sure they don't look as
bad at first glance but once you realize
that those windows are fake once you
realize that there is no outside or
fresh air beyond the light but a tangle
of wires and slabs of concrete and that
you're in the middle of a massive
sarcophagus your mental health suddenly
starts to drain if you want to see
natural light you'll have to March down
artificially lit corridors into the
common areas at the end the only areas
with actual windows and now we get into
the more Sinister aspects of Monger Hall
see this is all by a very conscious
design by Charlie Munger he deliberately
made the rooms tiny and windowless so
that students will be forced amid
incentivized to spend time outside of
them in the common rooms with everyone
else because supposedly this will make
students more creative and Cooperative
or something meaning thanks to Monger
your two choices will be a privacy with
no fresh air or natural light or B fresh
air natural light with no privacy or to
put it differently would you like your
mental health to be eroded by the wall
slowly closing in on you in your tiny
Outlet hole or the constant noise and
commotion in the coming room so Monger
Hall is effectively a social engineering
experiment by Charlie Monger this is the
same Force socialization ideas with open
plan offices to supposedly make people
cooperate more and we all know how well
that worked out but hey thankfully
Charlie Monger has also thought of ways
to mitigate the constant erosion of your
sanity caused by an inherently hostile
design like thrusters in a doomed
spaceship desperate trying to keep it
from falling into a black hole
in order to try to offset the
psychological torture students will be
subjected to the top floor of Monger
Hall comes with Cafe juice bar grab and
go market fitness center Gastropub
Recreation room grading room gaming room
landscape courtyard all in the name of
preventing you from going insane the
bottom floor features a bakery a market
multiple lobbies Music Room
multi-purpose study rooms a theater and
lastly a surfboard storage room which
hang on a sec which has access to the
outside that's right in Monger Hall the
surfboards get fresh out of natural
light students don't the mechanical
rules the refrigerant room the laundry
room and the fire water tank room will
get Windows students won't and as if an
admission of their sociopathy all the
staff apartments on the sides have
actual Windows what's up with that I
thought Smart LED panels are just as
good making windows unnecessary it's
almost like otherwise nobody would want
to live and work there because fresh air
and natural light are fundamental parts
of any human dwelling but here's the the
biggest ultimate [__] you courtesy of
monger and UC Santa Barbara the whole
idea of Monger Hall besides a
billionaire torturing students with his
social engineering is that it can house
a ton of students and sure this is one
busy floor plan tons of space for dorm
units or is it here are the actual dorm
rooms marked with blue this isn't even
efficient space use you condemn
thousands of students to windowless
tombs for this I mean this is just Jesus
Christ don't make me bring out the
[__] village house again you know
what I'll do it fine for those of you
who don't know the so-called village
house is hungary's largest Soviet prefab
apartment building the name comes from
the fact that it houses more than 3 000
people the size of a larger Hungarian
Village it has 10 residential stories
884 units and is 315 meters long I often
use this building to overlay on
dictator's [__] desert Mega project
to illustrate how stupid wasteful and
pointless they are and the Monger hole
now that I think about it is not that
different it's just another instance of
some rich old oligarchy wanting to play
City skylines in real life so Monger
Hall here it is overlaid on its future
side now here's the village house on top
of it okay let's just cut it up a bit or
would you look at that it fits easily
one student dorm room in Monger Hall is
6.5 square meters the village house has
a residential floor space of 43 500
square meters this is just the units
nothing else meaning if you build
regular Soviet error blocks instead of
the Monger monstrosity instead of 4 500
rooms you could fit
6692 where every single room can have an
actual window okay to be fair you would
need to merge some rooms into doubles
for that but you still have the same
number of students so there you go UC
Santa Barbara I've sold the student
housing crisis without having to torture
any students in a 99 year old
Billionaire's masturbatory social
engineering dungeon now I realize that
building hungary's largest gummy Block
in California is only a hypothetical
solution however students of UC Santa
Barbara have presented their own
proposals reusing existing Lots around
the university with up to
6573 potential new student beds more
than 2 000 more than Monger Hall these
students bring some hard data with them
and practically wipe the floor with
Monger Hall I mean it wasn't that
difficult in the beginning they bring
this guy out to speak in defense of
Bunker Hall where basically his entire
message is hey guys I know this looks
really really bad but it's not that bad
I promise he also makes the point that
Monger Hall cannot be fundamentally
redesigned to not be a windowless
student torture complex because then
there is no guarantee Charlie Monger
would fund it if the recommendation is
to proceed with major revisions well
then we're probably looking at least a
couple years to redesign the building
not sure that the donor is going to be
interested in providing a contribution
if the revisions are too major and by
funding it I mean bankrolling between 13
to 46 percent of the dorm's construction
costs how much will he donate nobody
knows okay let me get this straight UC
Santa Barbara let a 99 year old
billionaire without an architecture
degree designing a social engineering
student torture cube with windowless
rooms because said billionaire will fund
an unspecified fraction of the total
cost yes
see this issue highlights the need for
publicly funded non-profit education in
for-profit education University's
primary objective isn't the education of
the future generation but money thus you
get Rising tuition costs with stagnating
education quality and the university is
forced to prostitute itself to also
benevolent billionaires to stay afloat
therefore in the U.S what were supposed
to be institutions of Higher Learning
become real estate or sports team
management firms with a few classrooms
attached and sometimes one of them will
even let a billionaire torture their
students all in the name of the bottom
line I went to University in Europe as
an EU citizen I didn't have to pay for
my studies and my University actually
focused on Education and Research
instead of football teams or real estate
nor did the entire faculty have to drop
to all fours when a rich adamus rolled
into town and pretended their idiotic
ideas are his work of Genius so they'll
get some donations oh and all my dorm
rooms were normal with actual windows in
the end Monger Hall had to be downsized
by two floors cutting proposed student
beds by a thousand to 3500 in order to
be approved also due to reduced demand
following the construction of other
student accommodation projects nearby
that means that one positive the one big
selling point of this project the fact
that it houses a ton of students is no
longer the case really rendering Monger
Hall in its current form effectively
pointless a monument to the failures of
for-profit education and to UC Santa
Barbara prostituting itself to the
undemocratic whims of a rich decrepit
fool thank you for watching please like
And subscribe and don't forget to check
out my patreon if you want to support me
making more content like this
congratulations to UC Santa Barbara
student who stood up against this
[__] and I'll be seeing you next
time